VOTETION.
WE NOW HAVSURVEILLANCE VID
IN THAT CASEONE HAVE COME FORWA
ALL THREN  TO THE DEPARTMENT OJ.
CNN'S KYUNG LAH JOINS .
I KNOW YOU OBTNE FOOMG
NE VOTER'S COMPLNT
SHOW?HIISLY
SEOM
PARKING LOT, ANDERSON.
I WANT YO  LOOK AT I
E
NG UNUSUAL.
IT'S A VOTER WHO IS PULLINUP
DROP OFF HIS EARLY BALLOT AT
A DROP BOX.
NDWIS
AND IT APPEARS HE'S IN
SOMEBODY OFF THE
WE WILL LEARN IF YOUK AT THE
MPS TOPEOPLE.
THEN THAT VOTER IN THE
CAMERA VIDEO GIN T V
AND BACKS OF
T.
THE REASON WHY, IF YOU READ
THROUGH THE CO IS HE
OT PEOPLASENGAGING WITH WE, QUO
MORE OATSECOND.PND ACCUSING BEIN
AND  TTO PHOTOGRAPHS
FABYRIGHT-WING WHNG A CIRY FILMT
ALLEGATIONS?NA.
A T
EN REFERRED TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
LK AT THEM, THEY HE SAME IN MM.
E REFERENCING THES
DID VARYIN
DIFFERT  IPA
COUNTY.
PE SN RS THAT THEY
THEY HAVE
A CL TO INTIMI AUT
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH
FEN
ELECTION DX IN
OF ARIZONA.
IT'S WHAT E PRESS DOES IN
ORDER  GE OF THOSEPICTURES OF PF
U
VOTE.DEONT ARE THE CANDIDATES
FOR T THES
WAS DIRECTLY P THITION JAK WHO'
INBED INRIANSHE WAS
ASWH DO YOABOUT  WER VOTRSTH W
TO RESTORE TOUR  NE VERY C THERS
ELON E  ELECTIO CAM TO G
DONALD TRUMP WHO
0 ELECTION IN THE
STATE OFNA. DE HOBBS
E SECRETARY OF STATE
HAD THE EXPOSITE REACTION.
HE SAYS SHD
T SHES IN
Y TIT OFFICE PREPAREH BACKHOE T
DISPUTE THE RESULTS  2022
TIG E RUNNING AGAINST FO
GOVERNOR, E.U TO HOPE TOWN AND
HERSCHELALKER.
NOT EVERYONE FN ITIS CURRENTICA.
GALLAGHER.
>> RepteN BEFORE THE
RISES THE HOIC I
>> I LHERSCHEL BECAUSE H
ALL BUSINESS. Reporter: FOROR 4
YEARS TOWNTASCHE.ARK,SCHOOL FIE
HERE. I WASR
HE PLAD FOOTBALL.
>> FROM TH O
GEORGIA, HERSCHEL WALKER.
>> Reporr:E
SELF-PROCLAIMED PRENDAIN GIAS E
R WAENATE
CAMPAIGNNEARLYF SO
VOTED FOR REPUBLICAN DONAL
TRUM0 PRESIDENTIAL
DOWN.IS
BUT INARNED ,
IMPORTANSS
>> ReporL WALKERLEAR
WRIGHTILLE ROUTES.
>> HE HAS DONE CAMPS FOROU
IS r: BUT NOTIN
>> BUT MOST OF PEOPLE MOST JOH
COUNTY DON'T TNKTHE O BE RUNNIN.
>> I HOPE WEEAY DO.
R DOESN'T FEEE MULTI-MILLION DR
RESIDENT HASO HELP
WRIGHTSVILLE PARTICULARLY THE
BLACK COMMUNY >> WHIM, ONC
>> HE' CN IN THE
WAENCOACH ON ONSHIP FOOTBALL TE
DESCRIBED M  A GOOD,OLITE
GIVEN  T
ADDS LIKE YOU HERSCHEL P
AND AS A STU.>> STILLO, BUT, YOE
HE'SEADY.
>> HE'S NO>>ep IS A
CONCERN  SAY EY'LL STILL PROBABO
WALKER.
>>E OUGHT TO
AND LOOKE BEFORE RUNNING TO SEE
ABORTION FOR HIS ENr: REPORTS A
INCLUDING NEY SURFACED GATIONS
EX-GIREND'S ABTHAN A DECADE  NOR
D HERE
SAID THEY KNOW WALD SAY EY WEREE
BLJUHAD FOUR CHILDREN.
JEO'S
ALREADY CAST HISLOER LAMENTS
CAMPAIGN HAS TAKEN ON HIPERSONA.
>> HE'S TOO GOOD TLK.
IT'SURTI HAM
>> Reporter: DICKSONAY
UTMP
THIS RACE IS HAVING ON WALKES L
E CANDIDATDAY WITH THE KID HE K.
>> THE FAC